[Music]
it's et's social study what the stars
are posting online Elle King is a
runaway bride the X's and O's singer who
was set to Wed fiance Andrew Ferguson in
New York Saturday said she skipped out
on her wedding instead Elle instagrammed
a video rocking out to Eagles of Death
Metal respect and admiration for the
Queen moving on Mariah Carey and Nick
Cannon reunite for Easter Sunday the
friendly exes shared a sweet family
photo dyeing Easter eggs with their
twins Moroccan and Monroe yeah the end
of the day she's an amazing mother and
we focus on our kids meanwhile Kim
Kardashian celebrates the holidays with
her kids north and Saint West Kim K
shared the sweet gift she received from
Powell Chrissy Teigen this is not the
cutest Easter baskets made out of
chocolate bunnies inside and leave it to
the Royals to wear regal Easter
ensembles for Sunday service in Windsor
Kate Middleton looked poised and chic in
a cream Katharine Walter coat as she
greeted Queen Elizabeth with a cute
curtsy
you